[Music]
we're going to kick it off in cleveland
ohio with mike mike welcome to the
ramsay show
thank you thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help
all right so i have had a long history
of debt um
like credit cards and stuff like that i
have all that paid off um i'm a one
income household now a single dad i have
my kids 55 of the time
i have a truck payment and i have a
mortgage
my
my question is should i
take my truck off
and keep it and then work on my house or
should i sell it it's a fairly expensive
truck um
so i guess that's my question what is
this truck worth right now if you sold
it today in this hot market what do you
think you can get for it
it's
uh
i think around 34 000 and i owe
uh 29 and a half
okay so you would profit about five
grand off of this thing and you'd get
out from under the truck payment and
you'd have five grand to put towards a a
car
correct and you can buy cars
absolutely my other question with that
is
um now aside from my uh yearly income i
do have options within my job i'm a
police officer i can
cash out vacation holiday and a little
bit of sick time as long as we don't
call off six of the year um
i've totaled up everything and it comes
to about 22 000
over the year wow so next year uh from
basically from this december we cash out
every holiday so it's kind of like a
nice christmas check uh but from this
december until next december i i could
come up with
um
just over twenty thousand dollars um and
i was going to try my best to pay my
truck off uh and not have a car payment
starting january 1st 2023. hey mike let
me ask you a question
are you pulling uh like uh direct i
don't know if they do this in cleveland
ohio in in in nashville tennessee
if you go driving around on a sunday
morning around 11 o'clock in between 9
11. you got police officers out there
directing traffic coming in and out of
churches getting a lot of overtime high
school football games are you maxing out
your overtime possibilities as a police
officer
so i do uh when it it's uh
kind of first come first serve when you
sign up for it i do work as much as
possible i do have another part-time job
they work at a hospital
um as uh
as with as a uh police officer with my
department but i work alongside the
security there so that's an extra side
job so um are you figuring that out
are you figuring that into
this other equation you just gave us
no i'm not figuring any overtime and
also that is not counting
um
the
monthly payments throughout the year
that is just extra money that i can cash
out
uh
some now and then obviously some next
december when it comes to that time
again
yeah so what ken is getting at is could
you keep the truck and pay this thing
off pretty quickly and it sounds like
you could there's nothing wrong with
keeping this but based on the fact that
you are willing to get rid of it so
quickly which is rare for a truck owner
it tells me you're not in love with this
truck and you'd rather clean up this
this debt and just have the mortgage to
grapple with is that right
uh kind of i actually do love the truck
there we go i've been
i've had it for about a year and a half
now uh the only owner i take very good
care of it so my my thought process is
if i can do this if i can pay this off
by december 31st of next year 2022
can i just keep this truck
absolutely and move forward to my
mortgage yeah i think you can do it
faster than that what's your household
income
without the overtime
um is this before or after taxes uh
let's say before
all right before taxes 96 000
however i have a i have um child support
that i pay a thousand dollars a month
for so at the beginning so it's 12 000
less uh for that okay
so it feels like if you took some
overtime could you get rid of this thing
in under a year
i'm hoping i know
so my goal is a year but you know
uh with all the overtime and extra jobs
i think once i get that thing down to
you know near closer to zero that i'm
just going to work really hard
once you see the light at the end of the
tunnel you're gonna go full throttle on
this thing gazelle intense
absolutely yeah absolutely
i love it um i do have my uh i do have
about five grand in the bank right now
and that is after i've paid off all my
debts and everything i do have my uh
emergency fund of a thousand dollars
um
my other question though is i should i
um should i skip baby step four um which
is saving uh for the retirement i
believe right yeah
should you skip it i do have a retire
uh not
not skip the baby set maybe add to it um
because i already have my retirement
setup and i do put a little bit more
than i uh have to
into it i want you to continue on i i
don't want you changing up the plan here
keep doing the 15
you can keep the truck but i want this
thing gone in under a year with this
income and with us overtime and if
you've got cash throw it at that car i
want you to get rid of this thing asap
so you can live your life man but you're
doing great appreciate your service as a
police officer
more of the ramsey show coming up